next we've got the gift wrap that is
changing the gift giving game in green
news
did you know
if gipraft has glitter or foil in it you
can't recycle it really in the u.s alone
2.3 million pounds of wrapping paper
ends up in the landfill every year
it's like tis the season one minute yeah
and no you shouldn't be doing that the
next
but this season there is a solution
dissolvable gift wrap by plus
wow look at that outros
this paper dissolves in water and it is
printed with a bio renewable ink so it's
completely safe to send down the drain
that's amazing you i mean because all my
paper that i wrap with is always sparkly
hello
all right so now i feel guilty but this
is amazing
are you gonna are you of course you're
trying well i know i'm probably not
supposed to but like oh my god oh wow it
really does just wow
it just goes away
oh my god
i mean literally it it's gone look at me
i'm rubbing my fingers it's gone look
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna do it all
clean and tidy i'm gonna dip mine look
[Laughter]
i did it and every piece of paper has
dissolved into just ink on my finger
drew look
it just disappears oh my gosh
bye
bye
bye
i i would like to uh make a commitment
right here and right now never again
this is the only wrapping paper i will
ever buy what you're only going to throw
your money down the drain exactly
i mean this is incredible thank you
you have changed my life thank you thank
you
well
here's something interesting too we've
got a real vital issue to discuss and
like all important issues it was brought
to our attention by larry david on a
recent episode of curb you enthusiasm do
you all watch that show
well it it's now in its 11th season and
the question is simple at a dinner party
are you a natural midler
midler let larry explain
because andy and cassie are in the
middle that's what it is and they can't
meddle you have to be able to carry the
conversation you have to be interesting
you're the point guard this you're
distributing to paul
yes okay so larry is so funny and that
scene shows us what middling is i've
never heard of it well and good did some
digging on this and they say the best
midlers are extroverted great at asking
questions and good at reading the room
to curate the topics i
believe in my heart of hearts that you
are a natural born middler drew
do you know what's funny i have not had
great history with being a middler for
reals it's not because i think i don't
have the skill set i actually feel like
i would love to conduct the energy and
conversation in any room completely
fully comfortable with that especially
inventive questions my gosh if like yes
yes yes
i feel like i've been sat in a lot of
middle ear seats where the two people on
either side of me really wanted to talk
and not with me oh so i would kind of
like i just kept kind of
oh i know i know that makes me sad
i know
you're like more less of a middler and
more like a speed bump between them
i'm just yeah and and they're talking
over each other and then i'll sort of
lean back and then they'll start talking
back there so i'll lean forward no and
this is why i'm so adamant about round
tables and rectangle tables not being
too wide because guess what you can talk
to the person over there over there you
can engage in other conversations but
when you're in really big wide tables
you are really stuck with the two people
next to you well there's also an art to
choosing where you sit down i hate
dinner parties where your name's on a
little thing like that i'm like i almost
said i don't i don't wanna i like to
like go and then like figure out where
i'm gonna sit next to interesting people
this is a good debate clap of hands who
likes a placement card
who is like i will take my own seat
don't tell me where to stay
thank you
yeah uh-huh can i make you a promise
yeah any dinner party i ever throw
i will put your name right next to me
and we can sit there and you'll want to
see and you'll never need a middler
because i'll just hold your hand we'll
do it together perfect all right sit
next to any debt deal and we can talk to
other people of course you just i feel
like when the middle ear doesn't work
they do feel left out yeah i wonder if
bette midler's a middler
um
i hope she's i hope midler's a middler
and starts meddling
um well that's fun okay i i get that i i
but i like that most people don't love
place cards because that kind of
liberates me as a host to know that
because it's sort of like
just go and
figure it out let it happen that it
happened naturally but i do feel like i
get a lot of people like aren't there
place cards and i'm like yeah they're at
the country club go have dinner there
[Music]